there's a musician that i work with a
lot who leaves little notes in his
recording
he records from home and uh and so you
know i'll get he's a guitarist and bass
player and stuff and so i'll get these
tracks and i'll be importing them into
my session and starting to the
you know mix and and and apply the
the polish and what not needed to to get
these things to the finish line and then
i'll see in the waveform there's like
there's like a little rogue sound kind
of
off somewhere outside of where he was
supposed to be playing
so i go and isolate that and invariably
it's like hello austin
and the best the best part is when i'm
working quickly and i don't see it
and so i'm just doing and i just hear
this voice and it's like
and i think i think i hallucinate so i
ke and it just becomes this thing until
finally i realize
tom so i start like hunting i'm like
it's in here somewhere
uh because and there have been a couple
times where i almost shipped a mix
that had one of those things in there
where because it was it was like
loud and he whispered so in context it
was basically impossible to hear but
you'd catch the
sibilant like and so you can't you can't
hear that there's a
a word you can't hear what it is only
that it's there
i wasn't i won't say which game of ours
it is but there's a game of
ours that definitely ships with an audio
track of me going
of me going this is placeholder mike you
gotta [ __ ] delete this before you
launch the game
was it was in the game i thought you
meant the cough
and i was like this you coughing at
everything the cough the cough yeah well
that's yeah
i probably also coughed i coughed a lot
so at ign there was one specific
producer who
when he had a headset on if we were like
at an event and i still was having
i still had my microphone and he was
talking to someone i would just
whisper [ __ ] in the microphone but
specifically time it to when he was
having a conversation because i knew
he'd always be able to hear it
never got into break one of the worst
ones for that for me
was the day at e3 which is press is like
just
exhausting you're falling apart and i
was also very hungover
um which is a bad combination maybe two
hours sleep very hungover
and i was the first interview of the day
and the person i was interviewing was
japanese and they had a translator
uh so my producer in my ear decided to
fake translate in my ifb while i was
doing the interview
and pretend to guess what he was saying
based on his hand movements
so the person that i was interviewing
would be like
that's and he'd be like you whip it in a
circle and i was just like
the challenge of that moment is not even
it's not even necessary that you have no
sleep and be hungover for that to be a
daunting
experience but i love the just that
extra extra bit of spice that it
you know it's through this like blurry
lens of yours might have helped
that i was more immune to it because i
was like i don't know what's going on it
was he was a great interview it was very
interesting but it was also on hard mode
and just the minute that i was done i
was like what if i had laughed in his
face
what would you have done he's like i
knew you wouldn't you were fine jesus
christ
but i do like [ __ ] with people when
they have headphones on it's a good time
it's lots of fun to be had there highly
recommend it across the board
uh but i did have a thing that i wanted
to ask the two of you about today but i
don't know if you've even seen it did
you see the unreal
five update i have not watched it yeah
i i i queued it up because i know there
were a lot of uh
audio uh updates that were making the
rounds amongst my
my peers it is uh and some folks that i
yeah some folks i know at epic worked
really hard on
on some of that specific tech um and
we're
sharing it with a little bit of a like
you know like
cat like tom hanks going i have made
fire and
uh i so i was really stoked to check it
out i
i this week has been uh a bit bananas so
i
have not had a chance to uh check it out
yet only
only that it's supposedly quite awesome
it is i recognize that i should have
asked you both ahead of time yeah i'm
just gonna ask you to talk about it
because
it's really really cool like i guess e3
started this week so
obviously we saw a horizon forbidden
west and it looks
beautiful far cry it was this morning
and i almost woke up at 2 30 a.m to
watch that and then it turns out the 2
30 a.m time again australian time
was for a 30 minute countdown timer
my morning was messed up anyway but if i
had have woke it up
for that and i had to wait 30 minutes i
would have been like are you [ __ ]
kidding me
oh my god if any of those happen for the
rest of this e3 period where i have to
wake up at 3am
i'm going to madison buddy does that
mean that we're in this like is it like
e3 month
because i definitely have e3 related
things that i obviously can't get into
any detail on but which are
you know happening and and um
i thought that they were they're
definitely
not today a great way to phrase that i
would say yeah we're only three months
but i think at this point e3
begins at the end of may and then goes
to the end of august like that's what it
feels like to me now
it's okay yeah it's interesting i wonder
i wonder if
you know a year from now they'll think
there was a lot to be gained by not
trying to consolidate everything into
those couple days and you know even if
they bring a
live you know la convention center
component to it again
um if that would be kind of you know
here's our final weekend but it's been
weeks of
build up that we're just gonna kind of
call e3 now well the ea
conference has already been announced
for july 22nd
so that's way out of regular e3 um yeah
right
xbox this was this was ubisoft sorry no
go ahead i'm just gonna say like this
this was even like pre these exceptional
times we're living through
um this was already a thing that like
i've i've spoke i remember speaking to
several like platform holders and
publishers where
everyone was jealous of the nintendo
direct everyone
everyone was looking at that and going
nintendo owned the
universe of games for like three days
every nintendo direct and everyone
wanted to kind of re-reproduce that so i
think
it was already heading in that direction
i think they'll still do the razzmatazz
events as well but like
yeah the idea of like for us yeah
especially for like an ubisoft or an ea
like having an event that's just yours
that no one else is dropping any news
because that's the thing with e3 is
you're in combat with absolutely
everyone else to get any attention
um and all it takes is it it creates a
very
extreme difference between winners and
losers you know each e3 there's like
five things that get all gamers are
aware happened to that e3
yeah but there is hundreds of things
that's fired and cost the people who are
working on them lots of money to try and
get
that attention so i i think we'll do the
event still but i i
bet the nintendo direct model is going
to be with us i think from now on
well playstation's already doing it with
state of play yeah
um obviously nintendo is consistently
doing it and i love that nintendo direct
so i think that's so much fun to watch
they're lovely
they're really nice ea broke out a while
ago for
ea play which obviously again they're
doing this year in july but
i wouldn't be surprised if post pandemic
they start doing another in-person thing
that times out with
the e3 event itself um ubisoft and xbox
are around the same time as e3 i think
they're the 12th and the 13th but all my
dates are wrong because i'm in a
different time zone
so who knows anyway but yeah i mean i
feel like
the the value of e3 has to
prove itself even harder now that we
know that press can do preview events
digitally
that what is the purpose of having that
show because it is five days rather than
you know the conferences aren't actually
run by the esa they're totally separate
everyone chose to do that i
totally agree the publishers have almost
no point to do them at the same time
especially
now that they can just make them
digitally there's just no reason to do
it so the event itself has to
have some extreme value to press
or it has to go full comic con and just
become a fan show with
cosplay and panels that also include tv
and movies and entertainment and it it
seems like i don't actually know this
but
the e3 presentation conference stuff
they're doing this year
um this might have changed but the gist
that i had heard last year was that
keeley wanted to pull out because they
were focusing more on like having
influences that they'd interview or
streamers that they'd interview rather
than having devs or publishers that
they'd
interview right uh but i don't know if
that's still the case because now it's
um it's greg golden boy and and jackie
uh who are hosting it which is also the
first time the e3 has had hosts
outside of the coliseum so that's that's
what they're trying to do
i don't know i i don't know that there's
a ton of value to press anymore
um obviously there's still value to
publishers but i think you're absolutely
right mike and i know that they had been
trying to do that for a while
i remember when my state of play was
first being talked about
i probably no i think i'm fine nda why
is the state of flames exist now like
like that when that was first being
talked about it was definitely like
a lot of envy towards kind of the
nintendo direct model from
and it's been true of everyone since
what's interesting
you bring up comic con like there's even
arguments that like for the big triple a
publishers
events like comic con don't make sense
like you know you
if you look at like what um you know
warner brothers
have did with what did they call it they
did like their big dc universe
uh virtually random fandom that was the
one
and it's like that's that's arguably
better for them because they reach a
bigger audience they get like a comic
con
still you're only reaching the thousands
of people there you know and that gives
it an exclusivity
and you know everyone knows what hall h
is and all that stuff but like
at the same time like yeah there's
there's definitely
owning the channel by which people are
going to find out about your stuff
and being able to bring that audience to
that channel is so valuable at the big
end
who does really well at comic cons and
who arguably does
well at e3 and stuff like that is folks
at my scale
where you're not gonna come to comic con
for me
but if i'm there you might stop by for
10 minutes to check out something i'm
showing you and you see that in like
artist alley at comic-con and you see it
in kind of the indie spaces and games
conferences
like we're the ones who kind of benefit
most because it exposes us to an
audience who definitely don't
you know don't listen to this podcast
don't follow me on twitter don't i don't
i can't get to via my channels that
i have so how are you going to convince
them to wishlist mike
how can they wish list and pre-order
solitaire conspiracy
uh coming i just we just announced that
like an hour ago i'm gonna i'm gonna be
on that forever
it's on switch it's on switch um but
yeah no it's it's like there is a value
to that i remember we did
i you know we were uh um one of the big
games um
uh shows in the uk uh is the eurogamer
one
and we were there and we basically uh
got volume a bunch of press and interest
from players just because we were
essentially in the queuing area for a
big aaa game so what we did was we were
just kind of
grabbing people from the queue who are
cueing for the big thing and saying come
over and play our game while you wait
kind of thing and
holding their place in the queue and
stuff and you have to if you do that
hustle you can kind of get some some
visibility but
ultimately like ubisoft don't want me
bothering people in their queue they'd
much rather part of a stream that they
can just kind of
own the airwaves for a couple of hours
and talk to their audience so
it's gonna be interesting i don't know
if they reset completely
as press i did always cover
the hell out of indies at every event
right and that
for them not having an e3
i don't think will hurt as much as maybe
not having a pax or a comment that's
true
um yeah but the thing that i don't know
if this will happen or not is like say
the ubisoft forward
event that's happening will people watch
that if it's not part of a larger e3
if they don't care about ubisoft games
where previously because it was like oh
this is this week i watch all of these
conferences because it's fun
that's what we do this week are people
going to opt not to
because i mean playstation nintendo and
i would say xbox are going to be fine
every time unless it's like an indie
showcase in in those cases i feel like
they probably get less views but
i'll i'm interested to see it's not
happening this year especially for
ubisoft specifically um obviously
bethesda's just now
in with xbox so that's not in the same
mix but how the views change
this year because some of those
playstation conferences were getting
like millions of concurrent
live viewers and if they're just doing
entirely separate state of plays i don't
know if they'll hit
even the same heights because it's not
like the e3 event and you're not getting
people who
don't necessarily buy playstation games
i mean i really don't know
but i don't know that if a ubisoft event
was just in the middle of
november or something um and they're
always during a work day
if it's gonna get the same amount of
hype that it would during e3 week or the
same amount of views or do they
do they get the interest of people who
otherwise would not watch something for
their specific publisher
or do they just lose those people
completely i guess that's
everybody's benefit experiment right
that's the bet they're making
i think as well though i think the way
and this is
an ongoing trend of the last couple of
decades but like the way people consume
that information as well is very
distributed right so yes you have your
hardcore i need to see what far cry 6 is
so i'm going to tune in for an hour but
you also
and those people yes they're probably
less of those but the people who are
going to
you know be scrolling social media and
see like a clip or a meme or a piece of
content from that
arguably you're not fighting with
everyone else's press conference if you
were
i remember with um i don't know like
what the one that i remember because it
was uh keanu was was cyberpunk right
when when he came out on stage and did
his thing
the rest of e3 needn't have happened at
that point right like in terms of like
the memes the cons like like cyberpunk
just was
all anyone was talking about for a
couple of days and
again like at the indie scale we
definitely benefit from people thinking
about keanu reeves a bit more especially
when we were there with john wick
but like the rest of the aaa there
they weren't the meme whereas if you're
ubisoft and you can get that distance
you can be the
the thing that you may not be watching
for a couple of hours on the at the
moment it goes up but
you're probably going to see a funny
image or a clip or see some of that
coverage on your favorite stream
your favorite streamer is not choosing
to like put ubisoft in a two minute
segment in their summary they're doing
content about that because that's what
everyone's searching for for that week
right so it's
kind of plays into where we're at right
now in terms of how people actually hear
about video games
with my guess i
feel like the yeah
the show floor stuff specifically it's
interesting that uh nintendo would
always do comic cons there would always
be a nintendo booth at a comic-con
and i wonder why they took that approach
but obviously they had the huge enormous
boots at e3
and i kind of wonder if that helps with
that exact thing where
being in person and taking a picture of
the breath of the wild
to booth and then that getting shared
like crazy on twitter
is also a really helpful part of the
marketing strategy because those boots
are [ __ ] expensive
so expensive oh my god one of our ign
boots one year
was like the price of a house it was a
two-story booth and it was like
four hundred thousand dollars or
something i i could be completely wrong
about that but that's
what i remember being i remember one
night they're like like i remember
points in my life where i was spending
more
on the booths i was showing my game in
than my rent like that was
it was ridiculous it's insane
it's it's cool i guess if you can see it
from everywhere but not that many people
go through those holes
300 000 for an ign booth at e3 it can
only really pay off in my head if it's
in the background of a million shots and
it's getting shared on twitter
it's too much money a lot of it as well
it's like statements right is ign needs
to be seen to be the most important game
out there so of course they've got the
big booth
at e3 so a lot of it is that politics
and perception as well
i remember at e3 a couple years ago they
had one of the go-karts from crash team
racing
um like not one of them but like they
built like a dummy
posable you know stand in line and get
your photo
on the go-kart uh like right at the
entrance so it was
you know you walk in you stand in line
in the heat
the la summer downtown muggy
heat for an hour you get inside and the
first thing to greet you is this and i
remember thinking i wonder
this was probably like a million dollar
buy to place this thing here
yeah and i thought i wonder i wonder if
there's
any way there must be a way to
analyze the return on that investment in
terms of
you know like can they can they troll
like troll uh social media
to see you know how many shares of this
photo and then in turn
there are companies you can charge a
great deal of money for the exact
service you're describing
started one adam says it's gonna be like
which
the question is how many sales did that
make yeah but i don't think that stuff
necessarily translates
directly that way like it depends on the
company but
some of it is it is somebody's job to
make sure everybody is thinking about
crash bandicoot and that their job
doesn't
necessarily have to inform sales
it has to inform conversation
somebody's got a slideshow about this
somewhere where they're like this is the
amount of people who saw this
image of crash bandicoot here's the
amount of people who actually did this
like
here's the increase in seo for crash
bandicoot that we can correlate to this
like that that's a big industry that
that makes a lot of money
and i think that's the other thing is is
it doesn't need
the barrier to entry is a lot lower as
well from like a sharing and discussing
point of view
i know developers who've made the choice
to have like less
games you know less game demo machines
in a show in order to spend that money
instead on the kind of
the car outside all the kind of the
gimmick because ultimately like for
someone to step up and play your game
uh and these are the numbers you have to
start thinking about with these things
which
are like okay so someone's gonna come up
they're gonna spend
15 minutes member of the public kind of
playing our demo we have
10 machines 15 minutes those things open
for this amount of time you're literally
doing the math
like a few hundred people are going to
play this yeah that's not valuable
it's so it's well it's it's you to hold
it's a hard sell to like
get that because you have to like you
have to go well how many of those people
are actually going to buy the game
half of them have already pre-ordered it
exactly or told their friends or like
are you getting anything from it and
also there's the bariventry of a lot of
people don't want to play games at shows
or they they're going to be put off by
you know from seeing it and stuff like
that put a car outside everyone wants to
have a selfie and what's the great thing
about selfies everyone wants to share a
selfie because it's them
because they're the star so they're it
spreads more people like them more
because they like the person in the
photo their friends their fans whatever
like you can do a lot more in terms of
as you sail on like
mind share and all those kind of
trackable values which yeah marketers
like analytics on social media stuff is
astonishing when you get to like the
higher tier on this stuff
um and and and crucially as well
associations
which is a big part of that is it's not
just about people hearing about crash
bandicoot
it's people associating the the words
crash bandicoot with a good feeling
and seeing their friend kind of having a
fun time at an event
in front of a crash bandicoot sign that
also is something that marketers will
track and they'll track like
how you know the even like the wording
in the comments they'll realize like
that that has a positive outcome so yeah
that's
as much as it's a gimmick and as much as
game developers would of course
love it if the best way to sell a game
was to show someone a game
there are actually better ways of
selling someone on your brand and your
ip than
letting them play the game which is
which is kind of weird absolutely
there's also the um there's also the
aspect that some games just don't lend
themselves
to this kind of you know show floor
chaos sort of you know like like journey
would be a very bad game
for like but i remember a few years ago
at pax
rami was there with um nuclear throne
and he was like he was like this you
know this old-fashioned
you know step right up folks let's see
if he can do it like and he was
he was working this crowd around the
booth where
he was like who wants to see if they can
beat this level on the hardest mode and
if you do we'll give you we'll comp you
a copy of the game and so there was a
crowd watching these people step up and
it was
it was literally like the you know can i
guess your weight or can you
smash this sledgehammer onto the thing
and ramy's taken on an opportunity to
demo to one person for 10 minutes and
he's turned it into a hundred people in
ten minutes it's crazy it's
very in the game well but the game also
like
was the perfect game for that kind of
thing you know it was a perfect
game where you can watch someone play it
you immediately understand
what kind of you know experience they
are having you're not
it's not one of those where like if
they're in headphones listening to
dialogue
you're going i wonder what's going on
with the you know it's just some games
really just don't
yeah just don't lend themselves to that
and but that was one
i remember tooth and tail andy shots did
the same thing at
pax it might have even been that same
year where they were doing like you know
competitive multiplayer of just getting
people to come up and play against
random strangers and see how it went and
very enthusiastic like like you know
like uh south american uh soccer
broadcasters
like oh no he's a little like rapid fire
coverage of it and it
it's fun it's a total carnival but you
know there's crap tons of games that
could never
show well and you see them and it's
always a sad like
you know there's a guy passing through
and it's you know yeah you want to check
out the game and
uh well there's like this awkward like i
don't want to disappoint you because
it's just
us in this moment but honestly no andy's
gonna be really bad at it
like even some of their banners are just
text
like sometimes they just you walk past
their booth and their whole banner is
just text information it's like you
should have just had a cool image man
like you you're putting people off from
the jump but it's a thing that i've
spoken to a ton of indies about
i did a workshop maybe two years ago for
this kind of thing
was uh marketing and pr
are not things that you can just do
they're not things that the person who
wrote the code can just do and just be
successful at
and when you send me an email that is
i'm sure i've spoken about this on the
show before because i forget so many of
them that's
this game is legend of zelda meets dark
souls is how
every [ __ ] indie emails press and
when you're all doing that
i don't read any of them you have to
have to do something different
and i feel like it's it's everyone
thinks that they can market
and everyone thinks they can be a social
media manager i know that's a big thing
my social media managers i'm sure having
possibly hard jobs and i can't imagine
ever
doing that for a living uh that would be
so rough but everyone really thinks that
they can do it
so many indies don't don't think that
they need to hire people to do marketing
and pr and they absolutely do and then
they get really frustrated when people
aren't paying attention to their game
because they know their game is good
but they're not good at communicating
other people while their game is good
nor in a unique way
it always seems to be the exact like i
said exact same headlines in emails or
sometimes now what they've been doing is
free code
that's how they try to get my attention
in my email inbox but again when you're
all doing that i'm like this is just too
many codes
like i can't i'm not going to play this
game this just just says the same thing
as the other one
and there has to be strategies around
that and i do feel like
events are like i said probably really
good exposure for
for indies and i mean mike you could
speak to this but one of the things
about e3 going away
that is a huge bummer is the amount of
like back end business stuff that
happens at an e3
or at a dice or at a gdc um that is
actually helpful
for the indies or double a's if they
even exist anymore
where people are you know even pitching
their games getting their games off the
ground
that stuff that stuff being removed from
those events is actually has a very bad
impact on that part of the industry that
really benefits from those events the
smaller guys it's almost like we're
increasing the gap
if we like fully remove an e3 yeah
i mean dice is weird because dice will
definitely
dice will exist regardless of all this
because and as well
it's not a public event so kind of it
serves a completely different purpose
and
and i don't imagine as many pitches
happened this year like i know a lot of
pitches occur at dice but i don't
imagine as many occurred this year since
dice was not in person
oh no for sure no no no for sure sorry i
mean
i thought you meant like after after the
once it goes back on i think dice will
return shine
um but yeah no it's it is it is it there
definitely was kind of a musical chairs
like at the start coverage of everyone
kind of going
okay [ __ ] we can't do any of those
things so we have to kind of like we
have to get everything in a row so i
know a lot of developers who are like
okay
we need to sign this project we need to
lock this down we need to be doing this
or whatever
um because of exactly that that we the
the kind of the the gambits you can make
throughout the year the kind of the
those weird things that happen when you
are talking someone at a conference and
you end up like
you know pitching them an idea and it
flies that's none of that organic
stuff's happened
um i don't think i don't think it'll i
don't think consumers will spot a
difference i think there'll be like a
gap of releases or whatever but like
yeah it's definitely
not some people i know a lot of people
who were just getting started
you know in you know similar boats to
like the people who
opened a restaurant just before all of
this like if you didn't have your feet
under you like you were kind of screwed
by this whole situation
um yeah it sucks but it's but it's
it's yeah hopefully that's all gonna
kind of come back dice will be dice
but dice to be honest because it's kind
of an exclusive thing
and kind of an expensive thing wasn't
really kind of uh
you know it's not that accessible anyway
yeah yeah it was it was kind of
yeah you the the people can tell you go
on
well no i was just to piggyback on that
um
is you know being like someone in my
position
and any other freelancer is there's a
parallel
story to what you're describing because
these conferences are always
a valuable aggregator of the various
people that i either
know and have worked with or don't know
and haven't
yet worked with but you know by chance
we're in the same room together because
i was having lunch with a friend and
they said oh do you know this person and
that per i mean hell
you and i chatting on a on a beach in in
croatia
or whatever that was 100 percent true
yeah
you guys wonder croatia we went on a
date in croatia was that the first time
we met surely no
that was your meat cute was all meat
cute in croatia
like it may have been well i i think i
think i think we knew each other i think
we internet knew each other and i think
yeah exactly like yeah
yeah i'm pretty sure yeah it was it was
basically twitter dms until that moment
and it was like hey we're both at the
same event
let's meet up um and
and like that kind of thing and that's
one where you know
conscientiously seeking each other out
because there's a recognition of oh
we've never actually
hung out before we should fix that but
um
but uh other times it's it's yeah
well at other times it's it's been such
the organic
uh uh like i'm just with a friend and
and they'll say hey i'm going over this
person's house and it's like
oh i don't even know them or i've always
wanted to meet them or or whatever
that kind of thing and and there's no i
don't know that there is any digital
equivalent to that people tried right
did you get invited to any of those kind
of meetups and stuff just it didn't yeah
it was never
the same i mean the games industry
gathering
i think uh put on by guy bloombug just
hit
um a year anniversary i think and it
seems like that has been like pretty
successful and it's gone pretty well but
like i
you know i've spoken to him about it
just have no interest in talking to
strangers digitally
like that i'd just be so uncomfortable
it's like
chat roulette in a way uh yeah if you
remember that does that even still exist
i'm pretty sure it's just there every
day does that that's how i
said still except i don't even know how
to find it like is that like a website
or like
that's what led me to this it just
opened up a window and the two of you
were there and i was like i guess
they'll stick
something has porn on it it probably
still exists
so it's out there making money it's
doing just fine well i except the funny
thing with chat roulette is it wasn't i
don't think it was designed for that and
it just stubbornly was
like that's that's what it is just don't
deny it that's what happened with the
uno game on xbox
is it was just made for people to play
uno yeah you could like integrate your
webcam i'm sure i've spoken about this
before
with uno on xbox live and it was free
for everyone but then people just
started having sex
[Laughter]
because you give a human a camera and it
just happens no matter what it's just
inevitable
it's something that happened really fast
with wouldn't that happen with the
with not the eye toy with the um the
like with with there was a pia there was
a specific playstation game around the
time where this
where the was it ps4 introduced the
streaming
button and there was one game like you
could stream
with webcam full screen and again
instantly surprise me
yeah it's humans humans are fascinated
by sex
but yes they all like a chat roulette
and i know this clubhouse but
i don't know as someone who is like
pretty significantly anti-social the
idea of just
being digitally somewhere where you you
just have to talk to strangers just
sounds horrific like i don't want
anything to do with any of that
i i've i joined clubhouse i i don't
go in there very often mostly just
because um
it's basically impossible to multitask
clubhouse with what i do
because i i sometimes will listen to
podcasts where like there's a lot of
technical nitty-gritty work within
what i do where i've i've written a
piece but then i realized okay i need to
do this or i want to change
the nature of the effects like the eq on
that plug-in is not quite right and
there's like a lot of moments where
there's no actual music happening
so i very often have podcasts and all
manner of things queued up for those
moments
and um clubhouse because you can't pause
if you're not
you know it's not it's not pre-recorded
it's like basically listening to the
radio
and um so on the one hand i love that i
love the ephemeral
nature of it i love the conceit of what
it offers but it's i haven't been able
to really engage with it to the degree
that i
had hoped just by virtue of if i have to
pause
if i have to mute it to go back to work
and then i come back i have no idea what
they're talking about anymore
so i i i don't i don't uh do it so often
but the nature of it that
i i have joined a few rooms and ended up
in conversations
with people and i i love it as a forum
for contentious topics because
it's um it has a different rule set and
and and i think the the fact that people
speak non-anonymously
has a very different vibe and and tenor
to it than
twitter obviously which is just a
minefield of of
disaster uh so uh this audio
nobody can get their dick out it's great
yeah people people grapple with things i
like going into rooms so they're arguing
over
like really difficult subjects you know
and
and and people you know the better rooms
especially with really good moderators
that are really kind of proactively
taking it seriously
people try to earnestly get into like as
you can imagine there's been an enormous
amount about
what's going on in israel and there's
like people on all sides of it saying
like well you know here's
here's what you're missing though and
it's like they're they're not it's not
trying to score points
there's always some of that but but i
found you know at its best
it's a pretty good format i i will see
if it
really kind of i don't know how well
it's doing as a platform for example
like i don't know
what its total user base is and stuff
like that it's fascinating to me that we
went from
radio to podcast was the next step and
then podcast was supposed to be like
it's radio but you can listen to it
anywhere and anyone can have access to
it and then spotify
is kind of doing their damn best to take
that away
by now there are exclusive podcasts
exclusive to different platforms just
like the streaming wars
you know how much joe rogan makes for a
single episode of his podcast
look all i'm saying is so much do we do
we want to insult spotify because you
know
anyway great like
actually i'd be honored to work with
yeah
as a platform they're just great dream
just great to work with spotify to make
a million dollars an episode
is it really nice a million episodes i
don't think it's a million but it is it
is hundreds of thousands if not a
million i did look it up not long ago
that's a lot of money to make talking
absolute nonsense isn't it oh my god
oh i'd love it but then but so so that's
gotten more restricted and then
clubhouse comes along which is like what
if you listened to it
live like well yes we have done that but
they're just like reversing it but
theirs is still i think an invite-only
system
so everyone's got these different
barriers to entry on the thing
um and i worked on uh public radio for
three years in australia um on community
radio we were sponsored by the
government so we did get paid which is
pretty neat now show had a little bit of
funding
but even that was it was broadcast
nationally but in
i think also in new zealand and then one
radio station in the uk
and even that's a weird process of like
we could have broadcast that anyway
people are like we're good you're like
why would you not want the
free content that you get about any of
this and
and generally they're like no we have
licensing deals with other things so we
can't just
everything's just so [ __ ] restricted
in terms of broadcasting audio
in a way that it never used to be that's
a pirate radio is dead effectively
a replacement clubhouse so you can go
listen to elon musk talk about
israel or whatever what what what in
what way do you think it's restricted i
mean there if we wanted
that's all i mean well on clubhouse
but oh i thought you were saying like
when you say pirate radio is dead
as if there's barriers to people putting
out content if they want to put it out
oh you could definitely still do that i
just think uh radio in general
is is i i this is completely a guess i
imagine on the decline people are not
listening to radio as much
what it's it's aging up so it is
declining but it's
it's staying static with the groups who
are listening but they're obviously
aging out and obviously there's a
a limit past which they stopped
listening um yeah so yeah
the mortal coil coil they think anybody
had a radio
yeah and so well tv as well right like
basically everything i was gonna say
yeah but aren't those i mean isn't radio
once things like sirius xm and whatnot
became
like you know cars are standard
equipped to be able to receive those
signals now and and that
you know and i imagine anybody that's
got some show that they're
really into on these platforms you know
they have it installed on whatever
app on their phone for when they're
jogging and all that kind of stuff like
to me that's just radio
evolving and mutating it just because
it's moving away from the
you know terrestrial radio literal giant
broadcast
af am fm towers uh doesn't mean that
i think the form is well the issue so
the issue
is the walled garden and the proprietary
platform right that's the that's the
issue that
is inevitably happening is if as as
as it's consolidated as you have
platforms paying for content as you have
things being locked in under
exclusivities and to be clear
i'm a video game developer who makes
console games like
i'm definitely making products for
walled gardens so i'm not knocking
walled gardens
as a concept but i don't know what
you're talking about
i'm talking about uh soul tech
conspiracy coming to switch uh
people should play should should
pre-order oh and of course yes only they
go
but like the the crucially like there's
definitely
um there is a change there is a
difference there like in podcasts it's
an interesting one because it's it's
it's so quick like if you look at like
like
you know people listening to this uh
people watching us on youtube are
watching on a proprietary platform but
if you're listening to the podcast
it's an rss feed you can listen to it on
any device you can
there's no limits or controls on who can
and can't listen to it
um and therefore it's a kind of a
free-form thing kind of like
broadcasting from a
from a from an old radio device right
but then
you know with spotify they control their
ecosystem they limit
you can't listen to joe rogan on itunes
if you're not someone who's in the
spotify ecosystem you're locked out
um it's probably not terrible things
probably you can listen to other
podcasts which are much better
but the um there's also i think very few
he he's an exception there's not that
many that are
hard exclusives no but it's a trend i
think it's definitely a trend
and if you look at you can see the same
with um
amazon for example buying up a lot of
podcast companies there's a lot of
companies that are starting to
acquire these things never mind buying
mgm well exactly yeah right there's the
that's the legacy content that's the uh
yeah but well and the future of
at least the bond franchise right that's
the only thing that i ever think of
that's the only one that i was all bond
i don't know what else they even
stargates there'll be five stargate
streaming shows
probably yeah yeah i mean it's
definitely evolved
um but not no way that i like feel any
like i'm not like
old man yells at cloud like radio's
dying even though i had a great time
working on radio you know that format
changing
we still do this show that i can publish
on virtually any platform
really i don't think i could publish it
on clubhouse because it has to be live i
think
but we could stream it you know it's not
like it's tremendously restricted um
it's just an interesting evolution of
that and and
watching the way that people monetize
change i think is the thing i found the
most fascinating is
the way that monetize that radio was
monetized for us like i said the show
was government funded but we never had
any ads or made any
revenue on that show uh which was
awesome
very fun um but now do i think something
would be government funded
that would exist on podcasts or or
clubhouse unless it was like an abc news
probably not that's the way that i think
i'm very
like the bulk of like well not the bulk
a large amount of
entertainment in the uk is government
funded
yeah sponsored isn't the right word for
that though right like so we do have
that in australia too it's government
government funded but not sponsored
yeah technically well but like yeah
there's a grey area there for sure in
terms of process but yeah
it's um it's true what what would be the
difference i mean
sponsored does that entail some form of
endorsements
yeah the i don't know what it is in
australia but in the uk the
in theory british so we're talking about
the bbc so
the british broadcasting corporation but
b there's also all of our other channels
have
some degree of public money the
terrestrial one so like itv channel four
will take
those those resources in theory there's
no government oversight of programming
in theory um of course there are there
is yeah
so so that's the differences government
has a say sponsored you control content
or at least you have you know
you know if you're if we had a sponsor
on this podcast they would
absolutely have expectations of the kind
of content we were and we're not doing
on the show
um sure but you're saying if it's
labeled government
funded that's looser in the uk so it's
technically it's
i don't know again with is it licensed
for in australia
not sure but i know that it is it is
looser yes that they don't have any
control over what anyone says so like
our
government-funded news networks are
allowed to criticize the government all
they like and would never get in any
trouble for it but you could definitely
make a strong argument that
because the money ultimately the budget
for those news programs
is controlled by the government at least
in the uk
there is likely a pro-government stance
you know in bbc news programming
not completely it's not like state
propaganda
but there's definitely like biases will
creep in you know ultimately
um but um but yeah i'm gonna circle back
to e3 as much as this conversation that
we just got on was very interesting
that's what people are tuning in for is
our views on radio broadcast politics
that's
yeah and how things have changed yeah um
i
you know we we spoke about how this kind
of
um how it affects indies in the space
i'm just trying i was thinking just like
even while we were talking about this
what other
ways are things affected so like for
press
e3 again at ign made
so much money in that one week
that you probably could have kept the
the site is that just in terms of
advertising on the site and stuff is
that yeah
tremendous amount of advertising um the
other thing that makes ign the most
money is wiki's
the site could keep itself afloat just
with the wiki really
that's interesting yeah which is wild
because it's such a small team and they
absolutely were crunch um
maybe they've stopped i did see that
they had tried to at least with
cyberpunk but
uh yeah they they do so much work
i gotta say as someone who had no
interest
in remembering how to do the
uh uh core
puzzle restore uh thing in mass effect
one
uh you know what i'm talking about where
you go down into the core and there's
three columns
it took me ages that was i it took me
ages back in the day
and i was like ign wiki [ __ ]
just spoon feed me this because i don't
have time for this
but yeah but for some reason that didn't
translate to i'm going to use my omni
gel
uh which i had plenty of uh i love how
by the time i reach the end of that game
i've like like straight nines in
credits and maxed out everything and
there's just no where to go and yet i
won't i still somehow won't spend the
the i'm like i gotta sell these parts
and get rid of this
junk and anyway very silly but yes
thank you thank you ig and wiki
department for saving me
10 minutes or whatever of probably like
40 minutes
it's a lot of a lot of work um but yeah
obviously outside of that
e3 makes ign a ton of money for me when
it comes to content creation stuff
i would say outside of console launches
last year
which would happen for every console
launch um e3 will get me the most
subscribers
in a two-week period of time so e3
coverage i will get more youtube
subscribers than at any other point in
the year i don't know that it directly
translates to money because i don't
monetize that way but
that has happened several years in a row
um when it's calculated to one specific
week
uh and i'm trying to think of any other
industries that would be impacted in
that significant way obviously
like whatever industry is building the
boots
i mean they must make a ton of money i
don't know how complicated that stuff is
all of the people who work on the show
floor like on hand
to do that construction that's a loss
but i'm trying to think of
other facets of the industry that are
impacted by e3
not being contained to a weak like
austin does it impact your job
if e3 disappears primarily in the way i
spoke of a minute ago
you know every every year i i've gone
down to e3 most every year but
very rarely do i actually get a badge
and go inside because i'm just
meeting at the one of the restaurants
nearby folks that are in town because
they don't live in l.a
and so that and sometimes kind of like
with the story with mike
sometimes that ends up directly
translating by happenstance or or
deliberate like you know hey i know
you're looking for somebody right now
you know if you got time i'd love to
have a coffee you know because they're
actively looking for a composer and so
we decide to go have a conversation
so in those ways it affects me but um
obviously you know especially if it's
one of those where somebody's
keen if to have a conversation there's
no barrier to that you know i can jump
on a zoom if somebody actively wants to
talk to me
but it's the it's the it's the people
that don't know we
where we haven't met or we don't know we
would meet that's where it impacts and
that's an un
that's an unknown unquantifiable
variable i don't know
what i haven't yeah been able to
to to do i don't know what you've lost
um yeah exactly if anything or
you know it could be it could be
anywhere from i've lost a lot to nothing
yeah
and so you know but that said it's
otherwise for me
it's primarily this selfish
i don't know that it has any other
direct um
well there's only two other ways that i
could think of that it that it um
potentially
messes with me which is that every now
and again we'll do
like a launch trailer
you know uh like shenanigan
like i remember uh uh on the banner saga
2
i had a i conducted a live choir on
stage
at that then handed off to the to the
video and rolled the trailer um and so
it was like a stunt you know it was a
way to make it
cool um there's no real you know
press publish on youtube equivalent to
that it's still just watching a youtube
video but the idea of
you know we're gonna do and and this has
been this has been done
uh before you know they did it with the
reveal of
of god of war you know they had they had
an orchestra like a pit orchestra with
bear conducting
you know for like five minutes before
the before it started where they didn't
they just played the music without
saying what the game was and then
finally after like building building
building
you know reveal logo which was a cool
stunt so like to the extent that i get
pulled into things like that which i
love doing i enjoy these
these kind of showy ridiculous things
they're very fun
um uh those we miss out on those
opportunities to to a degree because
it's not quite the same as
baking it into the video itself you know
like filming
an orchestra and then throwing to the
trailer it just
it's just gonna go straight to the
trailer yeah uh in most cases so
that aspect but then the other selfishly
it's just
i enjoy seeing
people i i even enjoy i didn't used to
but i've come to really enjoy the chaos
of the show floor
and just kind of and especially when
there's people there who
like this was something that on hillary
was a wonderful gateway to where she
know she has friends
especially throughout south and central
america where
you know they're like working on you
know the
ign brazil team or something like that
and so for the it's like been their
dream of their life to come to
an ign and they they're there that year
and i've had i've met people like
where they're walking around just like i
can't believe this is
real yeah that i'm i'm here right now
and i'm seeing this i've loved
games and i've loved this industry since
i was five i've pursued it as a career
but you know where i'm from they we
don't do things like this and finally
my you know my work brought me or i just
saved up my money and brought myself
and like i really really love
i i get a lot of kind of osmosis
vicarious
re-ignition of my excitement i do you're
absolutely right
that's the thing i feel bad for evil for
like because again like british right so
like
i didn't go to my first e3 until like
after thomas was alone came out my first
gdc until after that you know
because you i couldn't afford to and
ditto on like comic cons and stuff like
like there is definitely like a a
homecoming for nerds who've like grown
up watching this stuff
sharing this stuff i remember going to
my first comic con
um san diego comic con and like being
there with my my boss and
and friend kind of at the time kind of
sorry my boss at the time my still
friend
clear that up um and like standing in
the hotel
and being and him telling me i'm like
can you like can you believe we're like
comic-con like it's the san diego comic
con so it's the big sound the big
comic-con
and i said this is this is this couldn't
be any more perfect and then kevin smith
walked past the window
i was like now we're at comic con oh man
it's like
it's like that's the like that's an
experience that yeah that's a big deal
for people and yeah there will be a
generation of people who
this was their year to i guess they'll
get it you know another time but yeah
hopefully yeah that part is
yeah it's it's it that those moments for
me have become the highlight
i had that i loved it and i think i i
totally agree like i would say
as press uh when i was or
even when doing content creation stuff
everything being digital and spread
apart is easier for me
it makes doing that content very very
easy aside from the time zones in
australia which is a real [ __ ]
but outside of that it makes it really
simple
what time is it there now it's 4 30 a.m
which means
austin you and i need to go we have
things that we need to do but um
i strongly agree what the hell is that i
have things i can do jeez
go take a nap friday night for me you
know
you'll be fine um
but i agree that the excitement
manchester red
the the excitement of e3 is the thing
that i love and i always said like if i
if i
became one of those cynical people who's
like oh e3 i hate e3 then i was like i
shouldn't work in the games industry
anymore the minute i stopped being
excited about it i shouldn't do it
because i love e3 it is
super exciting they did doxx me
which was a bit of a bummer oh were you
caught up in all of them
[ __ ] yeah thankfully i put my work
address in but it was my personal phone
number and i had
uh i found a conspiracy where i kept
missing phone calls it looked like they
were from australia
and their plan was to convince me that
one of my parents had died and that i
had to fly home
this was the plan that they had listed
on a forum was keep calling her from
australian numbers
tell her that her mom has died in a car
accident so she thinks she has to fly
home
that was just a fun fun fun cool thing
that they thought was that a prank or
was that like was there an end game
no just it was just a prank was this the
i think once you've crossed the line
into that plan you're probably not
completely there austin in terms of no
it was just pieces of [ __ ]
yeah thankfully i didn't i didn't answer
any of them and i was like this is
and i got so many text messages
otherwise it was completely fine
i wonder if that's how uh your
mysterious uh film composer who is
definitely
most certainly not me definitely to
austin uh
was uh i wonder if that's how they got a
hold of your number oh funny
um all right i have to roll to another
meeting uh thank you guys
this is play watch listen i guess i'm
alana that's mike middle that's awesome
we will see you next time
[Music]
no troy no troy alright buddy